[Musique]
le camp matheron explose de joie - du
carrousel du louvre ces dijonnais
célèbre aussi la victoire de leur
candidat
émotion un col est chaleureux et chants
festifs pour tous ces marcheurs
c'est surtout un moment historique il
fallait qu'elle le score choix net il
l'est parce que là même si on peut pas
s'enorgueillir d'avoir un front national
à 35%
le résultat est net et sans contestation
je pense que le débat du deuxième tour a
eu un poids pour une fois plus important
qu'à l'accoutumée dans le dans le
résultat
on dit souvent qu'il n'a pas un impact
prépondérant mais je crois que là il l'a
eu
et franchement je boude pas mon plaisir
ce soir
maintenant tout commence et tout reste à
faire donc c'est un rêve c'est un
souhait c'est une ambition
ces militants de la première heure
étaient réunis là où tout a démarré pour
eux il ya un an lors de la première
réunion publique du mouvement en marche
a dit joue derrière la victoire
d'emmanuel macron ils sont aussi là pour
se féliciter de la campagne qui nous ont
menés on est en train de se rendre
compte que finalement le nouveau une
prison de la république ce sera emmanuel
macron et je crois que ça va ça va tout
changer
d'avoir ce jeune homme brillant
intelligent qu'à une vision pour la
france qui a une vision pour l'europe
qui a une vision pour l'europe le monde
et c'est une vraie satisfaction de voir
tout le rassemblement qu'on a su créé
pendant des mois et ce rassemblement
évidemment
on va continuer à travailler à ce
rassemblement des français c'est ce qui
nous anime depuis le début un
rassemblement déjà bien amorcée et qui
compte notamment sur le soutien de
certains membres de l'udps et oui je
fais partie ce qui au sein de l'ue dei
du parti radical souhaite qu'on aille
plus loin qu'on aille dans une démarche
de majorités d'idées de construction de
quelque chose ce soir je crois que c'est
le terme d'une recomposition politique
majeure un double 21 avril à l'envers il
ya quinze jours une nouvelle page
d'histoire de la vie politique française
ces cris et je souhaite que nos
formations du centre droit il participe
pleinement pour ces marcheurs un nouvel
objectif est déjà tout trouvé
offrir à emmanuel macron une majorité
présidentielle